six seven eight nine ten
go
hello folks hey guys welcome to rational
science directly from frankfurt germany
it's uh about nine o'clock here in
frankfurt okay and what do we do in this
channel well we do physics
we do physics right
we do physics
rationally that's what's different from
this channel from all the rest
okay and today we're going to be talking
about bestie the flat earthers okay i'm
going to be addressing certain issues
related to the
flat world
and you know we usually make fun of flat
earthers a lot of people do
because um you know here we are in the
21st century okay
and
it's kind of like an anachronistic idea
to believe that
the world our earth our planet is flat
and so people immediately you know
laugh they say are are you serious you
know that sort of thing
but today we're going to analyze it
from some of the issues that the flat
earthers raise what's going through
their minds that's what i'm going to be
addressing today okay
and then of course we've got uh truth uh
it says the young man does not look very
enthusiastic
okay then we're gonna deal with truth
okay we're trying to figure out what
truth is yeah
i'm not enthusiastic to talk about the
the flat earthers again
i was like can you just call me after
you're done with the flat earthers
no that's the entire show yeah
i don't want to hear about the flat
earth anymore
and um and then truth what is truth i
mean we all know what the truth is right
and so we're going gonna find out what
that's all about then we're gonna answer
some questions that we people ask during
the week
and uh also whatever questions you folks
ask anyways uh there's also uh i forgot
the our science critic okay he's gonna
criticize me because i said that
mathematics is not part of not only
physics but not part of science and he
didn't like that too much so i'm gonna
address that issue as well mathematics
not part of physics or science has
nothing to do with science or with
physics with anything mathematics is a
language well we'll we'll get to that
anyways let's start uh first with
someone who won
um
the
idiot competition
uh idiot is a person with big ideas he's
got
he doesn't have ideas he has ideas okay
so we call him idiots
and uh
he came up with a
notion around about
the scientific method which he
completely took out of context and i
think didn't understand whatsoever so
let's start with him and then we'll
proceed with the flat earthers okay
let's go with him first and he says the
following okay
says bill says when you want to talk
about object you have to point to it
you point to a sphere and you say sphere
yeah that's how you introduce
objects in physics like if you're in
front you know you're giving a
conference or a dissertation or whatever
right
and that's how you would present an
object you say look this is a rope you
point to it and say that's what i think
is gonna an object that has that
architecture is going to simulate light
that's more or less how it works
so uh
he continued he says why introduce the
observer wasn't the observer forbidden
in rational science
and why should i see a sphere and point
to it right with the index finger and
then even say sphere and finally i have
to involve another human by telling him
look look where i point my finger that's
called a sphere
rational or irrational
well again this poor fellow you know he
he just took everything out of context
he doesn't understand
what the context is and so we'll let him
figure that out it's going to take too
long just to answer him
he's just got to come up the speed his
learning curve so uh
all we can do is just put him on the
honor roll you know and thank you
we always need uh someone to go up there
and get his uh
you know gold medal
okay let's move on to flat earth okay
and let me start with a synthesis
of what flat earthers in general believe
okay
you know there's different kinds of
people out there and some believe in
this and others believe in that but a
flat earther essentially is a person who
believes that the earth is flat
and they have
something in common with moonies the
moonies are people who believe that
humans did not land on the moon or
disbelieve that humans did land on the
moon whichever way you want to put it
and but not all moonies are flat
earthers but all flat earthers are
moonies okay
so here uh we illustrate that first okay
here it is
okay
uh all moonies uh i mean all flat
earthers are moonies they they none of
them believe that we went to the moon
because if they did
they have a problem with their theory
which is that you know or their
assumption which is that the earth is
flat
right and of course if we went not only
to the moon but we don't even have to go
to the moon we can just go out here
with our satellites take a picture of
the earth from from you know from space
and uh
you know you would
quickly see that you know the earth is
roundish spherical a globe right it's
assuming satellites exist and oh well
yeah dollar equipment is accurate
that's what they're saying they're
saying is that uh that's why i'm saying
that oh
all flat earthers are moonies they don't
believe we went into space because that
would destroy their whole religion okay
that's the issue but not all moonies are
flat earthers there are moonies out
there that engage in a lot of politics
they think that a lot of this is a hoax
uh something created by governments you
know that to fool us and etcetera so
they get it and there's some some of
these are intelligent people okay it's
just that they have this problem with
belief because they say you know i think
the government's trying to fool us you
know they have that thing going through
their mind and so
but so again just keep that in mind not
all moonies are flat earthers okay but
all flat earthers are moonies anyways
here's a synthesis of what a flat
earther is or believes in this is in
general terms it doesn't involve all of
them okay again you have different you
have a spectrum out there that can't
cover every little thing all i can tell
you this is in general what a flat
earther believes in okay here it is a
flat earther in general engages in
politics he wants to do politics and not
physics okay that's that's the issue he
he just wants to talk about hoaxes and
in that sense they're very much in
common with the moonies you know muniz a
lot of them just want to talk about
politics
and about not about the physics of it
here we don't do
politics as much you know we do a little
bit of politics but the main course here
is physics okay then the other thing is
that a uh moon is a flat earther is a
person who wants to do everything with
what is known as classical physics
they've never advanced beyond uh
classical physics meaning they want to
go to a lab like you go to a lab in
school you know and they want to do some
kind of experiment that they can see and
touch with their hands you know see with
their eyes touch with their hands right
there in front of them and they say well
show me that water curves or you know
that sort of thing they want to be
convinced by their senses
exactly but they're direct senses like
you know they don't understand what's
going on at cern you know acceleration
of particles particles we can't see or
touch that's beyond their experience uh
out there you know the satellites going
around the earth uh
you know that's beyond their experience
they say you know i have no way of
verifying that to touching it seeing it
with my eyes like close close i can't go
into space and touch one of those
satellites so therefore i'm gonna
withhold my belief that's more that's
more or less where it is they want
classical physics they want stuff that
they can see and touch right here on
earth okay that's part of the problem so
they have no idea of the historical
progress that's happened in other words
they don't know
why we ended up with quantum mechanics
or relativity and they could care less
they just want to stay in the 19th
century and before where they said look
all these people just did experiments
like you know faraday he did experiments
with magnets that's what they want to do
they want to limit it to that what they
can see on their desk more or less no
not not what they're doing at cern with
billion dollar experiments you know
they're beyond all that okay
uh anyway so uh space is beyond their
experience they've never been to space
so they say you know don't take me out
there into space don't talk to me what's
out there because i've never been there
i've never touched it i've never seen it
so uh don't don't talk to me at what's
out there that's something i can see
from here yeah space there's some black
talk to me about things i don't
understand or that i have no experience
with
that's the issue
okay and so they want to see touch
they want to be able to see and touch
everything
uh they can't see the air but i guess
they take down they can touch them
yeah but they don't see it yeah but so
either or i guess yeah but they can't
touch the chair that's on the other side
of the planet like in japan you can't
touch that one so there's that one and
says is that an object you know that's
the issue
they want to do things that are here on
earth okay and that's that's where they
want to limit their experience and their
uh theories and their discussion their
arguments okay they just want to limit
it to
earth classical seed touch here on my
desk or in the lab you know that sort of
thing uh they want to do experiments uh
or or they want to reproduce exp
experiences
that uh they've had maybe in high school
maybe in college you know that's what
they want to limit it to okay so that
other arguments are based only on that
and uh so they talk about practical
demonstration demonstrate prove to me
that the earth is round you know and you
know they don't want some they don't
want you to go out there and say look
this is how the greeks prove that the
earth was round the guy walking on and
so on and measured they don't want any
of that they say prove to me here that
this highway curves
that's or that i can't see the horizon
because it drops below you know the
the water below the horizon
that's that's the sort of thing that
they're looking at and that's what
they're going to limit you to and
they're not going to go beyond that
they're just going to stay there in that
little world well i think they want to
just minimize the conjecture
just passing it on yeah
you know the the the
the
you know
following of
they weren't in front of them basically
yeah and uh that's why they the last
item there was technology they they uh
are heavy on in technology because again
that's something they can see and touch
right there in front of them you know
they can press the button on the wall
and the light turns on so they they can
relate to all that because it's their
everyday experience but when you say
look
uh we're asking you to visualize to
understand
that's beyond my experience
don't talk to me about imagination
i want something i can touch and see and
touch etc so that's that's the starting
point and that's a bad starting point
because again they don't understand why
why the mathematicians had to go from
classical
mechanics to
quantum mechanics and general relativity
they have no idea why that made we made
that transition and ended up with black
holes big bang and all this nonsense
that we have today
okay which is nonsense also and i'll
tell you something i'll give you my own
five cents worth on that if i had to
choose between flat earth and einstein
i'll choose flat earth any day einstein
is even worse because he's saying
there's something called time that is
work yeah okay and that there's
creationism that suddenly the universe
popped out of nowhere
of course they don't go to that point
they always go to frame number two in
the movie they never go to frame number
one which is how did the singularity get
there in the first place and that's
where the religious people say oh god
yeah
that's the god
god's outside of singularity yeah where
are you standing i don't know
so this is the issue if i had to choose
i would choose flatland over
general relativity which is warp space
where time no such monster so the
explanations of flat earth are if
anything one notch about
above
general relativity
like that yeah yeah because i mean if if
they spent 100 years last hundred years
developing general relativity to come up
with black holes dark matter dark energy
big bang well you know all these people
wasted their time they did a lot of math
maybe their math is good who cares
nobody again i'm going to get to that in
a minute math has nothing to do with
science we want explanations we want to
know understand how gravity works how
magnetism works how electricity works
how the atom does its thing you know how
light works etc we want explanations
mechanisms for that that's what we don't
have today what we have today is a bunch
of math and irrational explanations that
support that math that's all we have
okay okay so that's our starting point
so someone makes a comment uh flat
earther and he says the following he
says
if it's just valid explanations you want
bill i can do that and base it on what i
can demonstrate he wants to do some kind
of magic trick on stage he says i'm
going to demonstrate you that i can cut
the lady in half you know that kind of
thing he wants to demonstrate
hey so when you talk about out there he
said man i can't demonstrate that
because i can't go out there i can
demonstrate here on earth you know that
water is level you know here here we
have water level
my glass of water
it's flat isn't it or relatively flat so
so this is the kind of experiment they
want to limit their discussion to this
is where the whole problem is
okay so an explanation derived from what
practical reference practical touch see
touch i'm going to take you to my lab
and show you that water doesn't curve
that sort of thing okay that's where
they're at that's where they're going
and they're gonna go with a little
experiment which uh this fall is gonna
raise he says i can say the earth is in
uniform motion the motion relative to us
would be upwards okay whatever upwards
is in the universe uh they don't care
because they're going to talk about
upwards here on earth like you know my
hand is moving upwards right now right
moving upwards why because it's moving
upwards with respect to me the floor uh
whatever other reference that you use
okay so this is the frame that they're
going to use the reference frame saying
this is upwards
they're not going to talk about upwards
in a universal level okay so is the sun
going upwards
uh
downwards you know with respect to the
center of the milky way is the earth
going upwards down they're not going to
deal with that okay they're going to
talk about upwards here on earth
so he says uniform motion dictates
weight that's just a description so far
he promised an explanation so far we've
got a description oh he's he just made a
unsub
substantiated statement that's all you
made so far okay he says uniform motion
dictates weight okay we don't know where
he got that he just invented that we
don't care if it's true or not we're
going to get the truth
so we don't care about that okay it says
it creates the pressure density
layers and gives us down a our downward
vector again that's a description so far
he hasn't explained anything he's just
parroting what the what he learned maybe
in high school or maybe just
got off the internet you know so he just
puts it on he just cuts and paste that's
all he did here okay
an object alone in 3d space 3d space
what the hell is that has no direction
and no weight
can he explain why
oh he he's just making statements
okay
all he did is put statements which he
copied and pasted right he hasn't
explained anything so far okay we need
to know why it has weight that's what
we're trying to figure out what causes
weight isn't he saying that the earth is
going upwards
well yeah but
let's get to the example that he's got
which is interesting bring in a uniform
moving reference frame to contact the
object a reference frame you mean like a
picture frame is that what you're
talking about i mean what is a reference
frame it's a concept you can't say a
reference frame what context the object
that's an irrational statement okay so
don't tell me about a reference frame
tell me about a tree
talk to me about a dog talk to me about
a rock and say look with respect to the
rock
uh you know or the rock touched the
object that you can say but you can't
see a reference frame touched the object
or came in contact with the object he
lost me i don't know what he's saying
anymore right
and okay so yeah so concepts do not
touch objects or contact objects and he
continues says now the object has its
weight and directional vector the
opposite of the action again
just baseless unsubstantiated statements
no explanation of just descriptions and
he thinks that he explained something
that he understood something i think
he's trying to paint a picture and with
that explained well let's find out if he
ever explains it because so far he
hasn't explained anything okay that's my
point okay so far we don't have an
explanation all we have is this guy
saying look uh there's weight there's a
reference frame that contacts the object
he talks i think my reference frame he
meant like a different like a reference
object maybe no
this language comes from mathematical
physics they talk about reference frames
especially einstein you know what they
do is they they put a stake in the
middle of space
they hammer the stake in the middle of
space and they say with respect to that
point that reference frame i'm over here
this is the distance this is the way
they put everything with we in relation
to this mathematical concept called
reference frame or frame of reference
so it's just a concept
and again the idea the best way to the
best analogy for it is you know put a
stake in the middle of space
uh call that a number uh number five and
you're ten feet away from the number
five that that's what they're saying
okay and they call that a reference
frame and that's mathematically you know
they need that for their equations it
has nothing at all to do with physics
physics you can have the reference frame
had better be a physical object then you
can reference yourself with respect to
that object not with respect to a
concept called reference frame which is
a point that has location according to
mathematical physics that's either a um
an ordered pair triplet or quadriplegic
that's what it is they're just going to
put a series of numbers say that's your
reference frame that's that's your set
of x y coordinates that's what they're
talking about so that's got nothing to
do with physics okay physics you have to
put a rock and say well my reference
frame is a rock now now you got
something where you can gauge distance
and whatever you want uh motion or
whatever okay so uh here's uh the
example this fellow that gives okay
again flat earther keep that in mind so
he says the following is recreate the
density tower talks about density he
thinks density is a physical object and
so do all flat earthers okay so they
like the word density
and it says in an accelerating vehicle
uh hang a helium balloon oh they all
love this helium balloon thing they they
all bring that
uh example okay okay let's let's go with
it let's find out where the sleeves
right the air is being compressed to the
back creating more density so the helium
balloon moves forward okay
what is he talking about okay first i
asked why he doesn't explain why he just
made a a baseless statement okay what is
he talking about he's talking about this
okay this is what he saw
and there's like a couple examples on
the internet okay so you can look them
up i brought both of them here okay so
you'll see what he's talking about
you'll visualize what he's talking about
because it's illustrated here it is okay
so uh
this lady she um accelerates the car
and you would think that because of the
inertia the balloon should go backwards
and it goes frontwards instead
and when she stops the car okay
in instead of the um balloon going
forward like you would like if you press
the uh
the brake on your car you go forward but
the balloon goes backward
so it's counterintuitive when she
accelerates okay she gets thrown against
the car against the receipt but the
balloon moves in the opposite direction
moves forward okay so this is what this
guy is saying okay this is where where
he's getting his uh example okay
and here i'm gonna give you a better
example still than that because this is
what uh this fellow uh comes up with
this is where you got it here's a a
series of three
examples the first one is going to be a
plum bob
the fella is going to hang a plum bob
you know what the uh they
they used to measure the walls like that
the wall is straight the uh uh the
masons
and he's gonna put a plum bob in his car
so he's gonna accelerate
so what do you think is gonna happen
well the plumb bob is gonna go back
okay
it's like you're standing on a car just
standing or on a i don't know a train
right you're not hanging onto anything
the train accelerates
are you gonna go in the forward
direction are you gonna
ain't gonna flying
we all know you're gonna go flying back
okay same thing with the plumb bike he
hangs it okay
he accelerates the car he shows that the
plumb bob goes backwards
he replaces the plumb bob he's gonna put
a balloon
okay the balloon does not go backward
the balloon goes forward the opposite
direction of the plumb bomb so that
we're gonna have to explain this well
what happened there why did the plumb
bob go backwards how did the balloon go
forward okay so the air molecules go up
to the back so that well everything goes
forward okay we'll get to that and then
the last uh example three example the
last one is probably the best one really
he puts water in a jar okay he fills it
up with water but he leaves a little bit
of air
in the in the jar so he has the jar
instead of up down he has it sideways so
you see the bubble of uh
of air inside the the um the
if you move that forward
the water goes to the back pushing the
bubble to the front
okay he's saying that's what's happening
in the balloon when you accelerate the
car the air in the car
uh goes to the back of the car and
that's why the balloon is pushed forward
okay that's the
explanation okay so let's go through
each one so that you visualize what i
just said okay more of a description
than the next one yeah yeah it's uh so
far we have no well we'll get to that
we'll i'm gonna get to that
okay so let's go with the plum bub first
i think everybody is familiar with what
would happen to a plum bop here it is
okay so he accelerates the car okay
you'll see it in a second here and as
soon as he accelerates the plumb bob
goes backward
okay straight forward you think you
would see the same thing if you put this
experiment at home
yes you would see the same thing you
hang this plumb up there it would go to
the back it's like when you accelerate
the car you get stuck to your seat
exactly like that no different than that
okay
and and that's even the air went to the
back of the car and didn't push you
forward for some reason i don't know why
or the plumb bop for that just the
balloon okay
okay we'll get to that and here's the
balloon okay same thing okay he
accelerates the car and instead of the
balloon going backwards as you know
intuition would tell you common sense
would
would tell you that hey maybe the
balloon should be act like a plum bub no
when he accelerates the balloon goes
forward
very strange very
counter-intuitive right
okay now let's look at the uh air bubble
inside the jar okay here it is okay
make sure you understand that
he's got the bubble there as soon as he
accelerates it forward you can see the
water goes back and pushes the bubble
forward
okay do we understand that
that's the issue okay so this is what
the flat earthers have in the back of
their mind when they talk about density
and um
and so the guy
says something along those lines he says
look he says
from this postulation i can say that
what you refer to as gravity is just
deceleration okay again unsubstantiated
statement just he's saying it's
deceleration so far he hasn't explained
the cause the mechanism the physical
objects involved in the word density
that's the issue that we've got before
us
it's an explanation no it ain't okay of
direction vector weight and density
layers no that's a description called
it's not an explanation and again it's
all these people who don't understand
the difference between an explanation
and a description so far he hasn't
explained anything in order to explain
you need the mechanism in order to get
the mechanism you need to identify the
physical objects involved in
uh this phenomenon called density okay
i'll get to that in a second even
incense show this is his
in his uh equivalence principle uh you
know to mention einstein uh you're not
gonna
come um you know persuade the jury
that's just authority you're just uh
yeah and second uh you know no flat
earther believes in einstein anyway so
why bring einstein into this at all here
for sure
branch to the einstein lovers hey join
us he's here in this channel we clean
our nose holes with einstein and
anything he ever said i intend to come
up with anything okay you're saying
his description doesn't count as an
explanation because he hasn't
established the objects yet and i'll get
to that i'll be more specific in a
minute or give me a second let me just
go through this no way for us to tell
whether we are in a uniform
gravitational field field what is a
field field you mean like a football
field
which none can define or demonstrate
again talking about demonstration doing
a little experiment on your desk right
or in a uniformly moving reference frame
again you know i don't know what a
reference frame is i think he's talking
about the frame of his picture on the
wall i have no idea what a reference
frame is no such physical object in
physics only one of these can be shown
practically again he wants a practical
demonstration using what classical
mechanics well that's fine and to use
that to extrapolate to the to the you
know greater world you do that too with
your rope yeah
i mean that's fine but
again if he hasn't established all the
objects then it's a different thing and
that's that's where i'm going to get to
okay this is where the issue is
and so here's a million dollar question
for any flat earther
okay but if but people aren't listening
that's the problem i can't get them to
listen to the question i just want them
to answer the question
okay
and unless you pay attention to the
question
you don't know what you got to answer
and right now this fellow hasn't
answered the question again typical flat
earther okay
answer the question that is being asked
before you okay
that's what we want what is the question
okay here it is million dollar question
that we want all flat earthers to answer
okay
the car accelerates you have density in
the
first in the throughout the car right
and then as the car moves forward the
density close to the balloon right is uh
or in the front of the car is less
that's what they're saying air is less
and in the back of the car it's more
okay so we have higher density and
that's why the balloon goes forward okay
that's that's the explanation here's a
million dollar question
why what causes
the air to accumulate in the back of the
car what's pulling
or pushing on each air molecule towards
the back of the car
i'll give you a better uh
one that you can probably visualize a
little better and i
pretty much covered it already but
you're standing on a train
you're standing on an airplane you're
standing on a truck i don't care or a
bus you're not hanging on to anything
your feet are touching the ground
right
okay so now the car the vehicle
whichever one of these that you choose
accelerates
what happens to you
do you go forward or do you go backward
well we all know that you know from
experience we're going to go backwards
right okay so we go backwards you talk
about inertia
inertia right
density air density maybe i don't know
why did you go backwards what's pushing
or pulling on you
i mean
for example let me show you something
here's here's a magic wand my this build
magic wand right
let's say this is simply standing in the
air somehow
in in the car let's say it's just
floating in the air like a balloon yeah
the car accelerates this let's assume
stand still
more or less right the car accelerate in
this standstill didn't take it with or
let's say it's in this room right
it's not touching the floor okay somehow
and the room accelerates this would
stand still and you say well that's why
it came closer to the back wall like in
the case of the car the car accelerates
or the airplane accelerates you're just
standing there you're going to get
closer to the bathroom in the back of
the airplane why because you say well
because you know you're maybe you're
standing in mid-air you know and the
airplane accelerates so you go backwards
but we're not talking about that we're
talking about you making contact with
the floor of the airplane your feet are
touching the floor of the airplane your
airplane accelerates should you be
accelerating together with the airplane
i mean you're in direct contact with the
floor of the airplane
what is pushing or pulling you backwards
in the opposite direction of the
airplane what is in physical contact
with your body is what i want you to not
only tell me but draw and illustrate i
want you to illustrate the invisible
intangible objects that are in contact
with your body wait what's the
difference between the floating stick
and the
outstanding well the issue is the
following you you have a fly
or a little bird
right it's flying in the airplane
so the airplane moves forward well we
can imagine right that maybe the with
respect to the walls of the in the
inside walls of the airplane right
uh if we were to film that well maybe
the the plane goes forward and the uh
bird goes backwards with respect to the
airplane okay let's assume that's the
case and people would say well yeah
because it's not in contact with the
airplane my point here is that if you
are standing on the airplane why do you
go back now now you should go together
with the airplane could you huh
why would you
you're not a part of the plane so why
would you well because you're in contact
with the airplane i mean why doesn't why
doesn't the seat go back the seat you
know that where you sit that one goes
with the airplane
well yeah but that one goes with the
airplane i mean i don't know but it
tries to go back
i know i know but this is the point the
point is that i'm in contact with the
airplane right i'm standing directly
with the airplane why doesn't it like a
tree that's planted in the ground you
know if you move the ground the tree
would go with the ground because you
know it's stuck to the ground right more
or less like that i'm saying that you
know you're you're stuck to the not
stuck completely but you're in contact
with the airplane with the surface of
the airplane
why do you go backwards what's this
inertia thing don't tell me you're not
destiny don't tell me
don't use any of the concepts i need a
physical object that's in contact with
you that's pulling or pushing on you
okay that's what i want i want you to
draw
illustrate show me anywhere on the
internet the physical object that is
pushing or pulling on you when the
airplane accelerates that's that's the
question okay you have to identify that
otherwise you don't have an explanation
you can't talk about gravity you can't
talk about density you can't talk about
any of these concepts because you don't
understand them you can't tell me the
mechanism of what's pulling or pushing
you back towards the back of the
airplane or the back of the truck like
that phrasing it's not really pushing or
pulling you it's the plane that's going
forward and you're not you're just
standing why why am i going backwards
something is in contact with my body the
plane is going forward i thought yeah
yeah but i'm in contact see with a fly
you can say the fly is not in contact
with the airplane but i'm in contact
with the airplane that doesn't change
anything why why would it why wouldn't
it
why wouldn't it what's what's why would
it is it weirder no no real question
why wouldn't it is the question i i need
to know the physical object that's in
contact
because the airplane is in contact with
my with my feet
so you would think that that's has more
influence
than the invisible stuff that is pushing
or pulling me backwards because if i'm
in contact with a with a floor you would
think that i would move together with a
floor why not
why not well i'm not good so what so
what if i'm not glued why do why do i go
backward is the question but you're not
going backwards i'm going backwards
with respect to the airplane i'm going
backwards i'm going to the wall back
wall of the airplane
but the plane is going forward well i
don't care i'm saying why am i going
backwards with respect to the plane why
don't i move with the plane
because you're not glued to it yeah i
know so what uh what's what's keeping me
from going what's keeping me from going
together with the airplane with a bus
with a train that's the question that's
a weird phrase that's that's a loading
well i don't yeah no it's not a loaded
you need to identify the physical object
that's in contact with my body there is
something in contact with my body and
that's what we're going to get to next
here we're going to see that okay in
other words um
here's uh
here's my explanation okay
this is again my explanation so that you
see where i'm coming from uh
for this issue okay
uh
first of all you know you can't use any
of these to explain
what i just asked in other words what's
in contact with my body you can't use
the word weight mass density
deceleration reference frame demonstrate
experiment practical none of that
because they have no meaning yeah what
we want is the physical object i want
you to draw it yeah i want you to
illustrate though the invisible object
that's in contact with my bar with every
atom show the movie is more specific
well yeah because when i say for example
when when these people say that um air
goes to the back of the car
what is pulling or pushing on each atom
each molecule of air what is pulling or
pushing on why does it stay or why does
it stay where it's at or where does it
travel together with the car why does
the density accumulate in the back of
the car that's the question what's
pulling or pushing on each molecule of
air okay
and you say there's nothing there
because you can't see it
i don't care that means that you don't
have a mechanism you don't have an
explanation for density which is what
i'm asking you to explain
i want to see the mechanism mechanism
means objects means you have to identify
the invisible objects that are in
contact with air which is by the way
also invisible
why does the air accumulate in the back
of the car that's the question that say
it does and because of that the balloon
moves forward now tell me why the air
goes to the back of the room of the back
of the car that's the question okay
let's get it right
okay so uh how do we answer this well we
start with this which is our
interconnected universe okay we're
saying that all atoms in the universe
all atoms in existence are physically
interconnected an atom is attached to
any other atom in the universe
everything is physically interconnected
we start with the single thread
which turns into a rope which
interconnects any two atoms okay
and once we have this we can see why uh
there is no action at a distance it's
just that we cannot see
what's between the chair and the table
that's what it is we can't see what is
connecting the atoms of the chair to the
atoms of the table
okay that's the that's the issue before
us and if you're gonna do it without an
interconnection
if you're saying there's nothing there
because you cannot see or touch it then
all you are doing is black magic
you're saying that this atom over here
affects that one over there and there's
nothing in between them
you're doing the same thing as quantum
mechanics they explain everything with
action at a distance gravity action at a
distance magnetism action at a distance
okay why because here we have two
magnets okay two little round ones there
okay
and you can see that one attracts the
other
is
see if you can put your hand between
there
did you hit anything did you touch
anything i think so
so you can't see or touch anything
that's between the two magnets
so how is this magnet affecting that one
such that you know i can already see if
i hold them very lightly i can
see there it's already pulling on the
inside no matter what i do there's
something on the inside that's pulling
them together we can't see it we can't
touch it it's there there's a physical
object in there you say there's nothing
there because you can't see or touch it
you're doing black magic you're
explaining this with black magic you
might as well use
uh
spirits and say well the spirit state or
god with his magic wand you can do
whatever you want because you're talking
about black magic man the field doesn't
mean anything when they say magnetic
field they're like what is it yeah you
got to just say in this area something's
happening oh great
i got this
that is what the word field meant you
know when faraday invented the word
field i think it was 1845 some people
had traced it that far back
1845 he invented this word field what is
the word field well as far as he was
concerned he he dealt with electricity
and magnets he said look there's a
region in there and there's something in
there the lines of force we can't see or
touch it there's some exotic matter
there that we can't see or touch but
there's something there and we can
sprinkle iron filings to know which
direction
motion is going but we don't know what
the what is causing the motion and you
said it right there
you throw iron filings are you saying
that nothing compelled the iron filings
to line up in a certain way around the
magnet well the field but that's the
same yeah yeah
all you're saying is what is there a
field field is defined by mathematicians
as value at each point in space or
they're talking about is numbers they're
saying there's a certain strength at
different distances that's all they're
saying so field is just a bunch of
numbers okay you can't say the field
move the wall but back to back to this
why did why do i not
why am i not carried by the plane when
the plane accelerates forward okay so uh
here's uh
my my explanation if every atom in the
universe is
uh connected to all others here i show
an example why the earth is round
spherical not flat okay so is every
other celestial object out there i would
say 99 of celestial objects in the
universe are
uh spherical monospherical sunny
spherical
all of them are spherical why because of
gravity what is gravity gravity is that
every atom in the universe is physically
interconnected with all others i guess
gravity is a symptom of that
yeah it's it's the result or the um
the result of of gravity right
so or or the word we use to express why
everything tends like in this case
towards the center because if you have
uh water which is the blue part the very
dark blue and then you have air which is
the light blue layers there well if you
have an atom in air
it's pulled towards the center of the
earth because that's where most of the
matter is concentrated at so
all these atoms that you see on the
periphery that i drew there you can see
they're all essentially tucked towards
the center and that will describe a ball
okay that's what you you're gonna get if
you have this uh notion of gravity okay
so i can explain why everything falls
towards the center of the earth because
all atoms are physically interconnected
and there is no action at a distance as
the flat earthers would have you believe
because they can't see or touch the
mediators and we're not going to be able
to see them in the lab we're not going
to be able to demonstrate run an
experiment where we prove which is
something related to believe prove to
the jurors to the jury
that uh that there is something there
between any two atoms there's no way you
can prove that because it's invisible
and intangible therefore experiments
will not help us at all you cannot prove
gravity with experiments you can prove
it to some people
that's but we're not interested in
proving first of all we're not
interested in proving second i don't
think you can prove what are you gonna
prove for invisible intangible well
proving is is proved to me that there's
something we do terrible you're not
getting it proving is the fault of the
person who's it proved proved to
you can prove
whatever you want depends on who you're
talking to
if you talk about yeah
yeah
you're you're addressing belief you're
not addressing
uh understanding what we want is
understanding not believe not do
knowledge you know do flat earthers
believe in flight
well flight i guess they believe in
because i'm sure a flat earthers like
airplanes yeah yeah yeah i think they
they just don't think that everything
goes out there yeah they don't go the
extra mile okay gotcha
okay okay so a fellow says okay i showed
them how to curve water you curve water
out there in space you can't curve water
here in the glass i think that was
actually a question i wrote here are the
edges of the cup of the water lower than
the center ones like if you if you went
in there with a with a like nano scope
well
that a little bit curved yeah of course
yeah if if you could if you could look
at each atom individually the one that
the edges should be curved yeah assuming
yeah
but they say uh you're cheating because
that's not our everyday experiences so
you're you're going with uh sams and
atomic force microscopes and it's beyond
that
yeah you're doing something some trees
are using something we have no access to
every day and so i don't believe in that
that's the way they answer that
okay so the fellow says makes this
comment he says the following says the
question and the observation is about
how water behaves here on earth in our
reference frame again he wants this this
is this is the extent of his experience
he says look here i can show you it's
flat
that's it he says i'm not going to go
beyond this that's that's the extent of
his
understanding of his uh ignorance maybe
but it isn't that's kind of he's he's
wrong but off the get-go that isn't flat
no no but assuming it's completely flat
let's concede it's flat i mean
irrelevant i mean
this is not the experiment to prove that
water occurs it is for him yeah that's
why proving is the problem
that's why we don't prove in science and
friends proof means that you're going to
believe and you can believe anything you
want i don't care yeah you can believe
the earth is flat anytime someone says
it's been proven the question always
remains to whom
so
you know
okay so he says bill's reasoning is to
jump to a reference frame that he sees
on tv that is not within our reference
frame no no what i'm saying is it's got
nothing to do with tv it's got to do
with i mean here here you have uh
here you have the moon is this a paper
moon that we have a flat moon that we
have out there in space they say it is
you know i mean are we talking about a
flat moon a flat disc that's out there
floating or do you think the moon is
spherical do you think the sun is
spherical or is it a flat disc yes the
flat moonies too
paper moon that's the other question why
does the if the earth is going up the
whole time why does it never crash into
the moon or the sun
they never explained that one either
yeah
anyways uh so the question is this is
not a question of uh me seeing something
on tv this has to do with
visualization you should be able to
visualize to say close your eyes and
imagine how mother nature father
universe god the devil whoever you
believe in how they could be doing
gravity that's the issue okay
and so we say look the moon is spherical
the sun is spherical all objects out
there are spherical now if you have
problems with that you think
everything's just a flat disc floating
up there you know jupiter and whatever
or jupiter's too far away for your
understanding you don't care about that
well you know then we got problems
because all you're doing is enclosing
yourself within your ignorance you're
saying oh i'm not going to look through
galileo's scope
to
verify that there are four galilean
moons out here it wouldn't even work if
the moon were flat because if you look
at it from different angles it wouldn't
be a circle right
no but i guess see they say that the
moon is just flat and you're just
staring at a flat end
i think that's i don't know if it's a
circle and you're looking at it from an
angle it would be an oval
yeah yeah that's another one uh but you
can
so so he says even if i grant that it is
a real reference frame it's uh got
nothing to do with how things behave
here in our shared reality again he
wants to bring us back to earth just a
little lab what he did maybe in high
school or elementary school he says i
just want to limit my understanding to
what's inside my little room
i want to be able to you know mix
liquids and it is there i mean the only
way the the moon and this let's just
take the moon as an example the only way
that could be a circle that could be
seen as a circle from anywhere you stand
on the earth assuming the earth will be
flat is if the moon were a sphere yeah
otherwise you'd see weird ovals in
different shapes yeah yeah yeah so
that's that's just why their own logic
it falls apart so he says you are
ignoring direct demonstration he wants a
demonstration of gravity okay well
here's a demonstration of gravity okay
how's that there's a demonstration of
gravity did you see what caused
the uh
one to fall downwards okay
so so yeah it's uh these people are
asking for the for something that's
irrational they're asking to see that
which is invisible and intangible they
say i want to see it i want to touch it
i want to run an experiment i want you
to demonstrate so what are you going to
so you know here here's a pencil right
i'm going to let go of it it's going to
fall to the floor we all know that but
see can you see or touch anything that's
in this region that's the question
and if you say there's nothing there
you're explaining this experiment you're
explaining it with black magic is that
the reason you can't have the word
density why you rejected the c and touch
notion because i mean even magnetism for
example there's no way to touch or see
the actors in the field exactly so
seeing and touching
is just a bad
measure
of
telling what is acting upon things and
that was that why you had to come up
with the shape thing the no no because
really that came afterwards the
explanations say no these people harping
i was saying what is the problem the
problem is that all these people
including the mathematicians the
mathematical physicist the electric
universe the flat earthers the
uh john chappelle society all these
people are talking about see and touch
experiment demonstration proof what's
wrong with you can't do that because
an object is not that which you can see
and touch
or touch
and existence is not that which you can
see or touch you can't say the chair
exists because i can see and touch it
that's an irrational statement
the chair exists by definition whether
you can see or touch it
or not
and people don't under that's where the
problem is well they have the wrong
definition of the word object and the
wrong definition or irrational
definitions of the word exists well it
also falls apart when there
if you were to assume there are objects
that do exist however you define exist
yeah that are untouchable and unseeable
then you got a problem just by your own
definitions
not by yours i'm saying yeah yeah
if someone says exists to see and touch
yeah but if if we just assume
that there are things that exist that
you can't see and touch then you got a
problem because then does it exist or
doesn't it yeah and and we're going to
see that
there's a good example a couple of
questions that come up here uh people
think that an object is that what you
can see or touch and existence is also
that which you can see or touch meaning
that the word exists and the word object
or sin in it they can get their line
they can only deal with that which they
can see or touch turns out you can't see
the air you can touch it but you can't
see it so it already failed one of the
criteria uh you can say well i can touch
it okay what did you touch and you can't
see it what is it maybe you touch a
spirit i mean i don't know what you
touch but forget about that can you see
or touch the table that the klingon has
on the other side of the universe
and you believe in klingons
and who can see and touch because it
might be a dead guy or might be a blind
guy or it might be a guy in a coma and
that guy touch it i mean well you can't
see or touch the atom the individual
atoms that make up your table you can
you can see or touch the table because
it's made out of gazillion's atoms but
you can't see individual atoms you can't
say oh i can see your touch a hydrogen
atom that's made
that makes up part of my table you can't
do that you can't see or touch it
you can't see it with a
atomic force microscope you cannot see
it with a
sem scanning electron microscopy
i see it it's just really low resolution
right no no you can't you another
hydrogen atom you can see a bigger atom
but you can't see a hydrogen atom and
the atoms that we can see with the sam
or with atomic force microscope are from
a bird's eye perspective all this is a
little balloon there that's it that
we've never seen the little bead rolling
around
in the um in the uh what is it in the uh
orbital okay we haven't seen that we
haven't seen a bead going around the
electron you know so that we've never
seen what we see is a balloon like from
a bird's eye perspective they say that's
an atom okay right what did we see what
did we stare at can we see in the center
of that atom and find out what the
proton looks like obviously not okay we
can't see a proton okay so the question
is does that mean that there is no such
thing as a proton does it mean that it
doesn't exist because you can't see or
touch it well that's the problem with
seeing touch the biggest problem i see
with that is whatever make whenever
object
facilitates or is the cause of sight to
sight as as such
cannot be seen
the object itself that causes that or
that mediates that of course you can't
see it you can't see the mediator of
light yeah because
you're actually going to see the
mediator
of the thing that you're using to see it
yeah yeah so now you have to use your
brain for you gotta imagine these things
you can't say let's go to the lab and
let's see and touch it let's run into my
definition
irrational you're making an irrational
statement and flat earthers want
demonstration proof experiments
and so do the electric universe and all
these other people like john chappelle
what do you keep beating up on the flat
earthers what did they ever do to you
what's the obsession
okay so uh here's the comment guy makes
she said bill should learn the
difference between microscopic and
invisible he doesn't like the fact that
an object is that which you can
that has shape he says he wants to
say that an object is that which you can
see or touch okay and so the question
here he says should learn the difference
between microscopic and invisible he
thinks that all objects have um can be
seen or touched but some are just very
microscopic not invisible
okay so he's saying that an atom a
hydrogen atom is not really invisible to
our eyes it's just microscopic that's
his argument there is no such thing as
invisible or intangible objects
well what's the mediator of light what's
the mediator of gravity here's uh
gravity okay let's uh let me push this
out for a second here are we gonna see
gravity again we're gonna see gravity
again here we're here to see the effects
of gravity here we have a benzo okay do
you see or can you what do you think is
gonna fly up but they say i break too
many lead
in the pencil all my pencils are broken
from dropping them so much okay so can
you see anything
above or below the pencil can you touch
anything other than the air above or
below the pencil
what's causing this to happen
why does it why didn't it fall to the
ceiling
and there's something that is in contact
with the skin of this pattern so if you
say there's nothing no physical object
no nothing that exists
that is causing this to happen you are
introducing black magic
you're saying that this happens by
action at a distance the earth has some
magical influence over this and pulls it
down
and you cannot say density weight
a reference frame none of that you need
a physical object you have to tell me
what physical object is in contact with
a pencil you keep throwing it down
that's what it is you're cheating okay
let me throw it up oh it still falls out
trick shot
that's your theory failed okay
okay so uh the fellow says you know no
such thing as invisible intangible
object he says atoms are microscopic not
invisible yeah correct and we're not
saying that they're invisible we can't
see them except with some kind of device
right if something can't be seen or
touched by an instrument by an
instrument known to men like dark matter
or or electromagnetic ropes there is no
reason to assume it exists
if it can't be seen or touched there's
no reason he rejects it out of his
experience wow he he dies on that hill
yeah yeah chooses to die on the sea and
touch hill if they can't be touched or
seen then it doesn't exist not only it
doesn't it's not even an object it's not
a thing yeah yeah it's not even okay if
you can't see or touch it see that's you
and the other another fellow says no
such thing as invisible intangible
physical objects invisible intangible
object is an oxymoron that can't be true
okay and again what is the problem the
problem is that these people are running
with an irrational definition of the
word object or what a thing is wait okay
yeah black holes those also can't be
seen or touched well black hole has a
different problem because see we define
an object as that which has shape no no
i mean by their own definition oh yeah
you can't see you're touching
you're talking to the wall because they
don't believe in black holes either
which is correct
they're intelligent in that sense yeah
no black holes okay so here we have it
okay and again an object is that which
has
uh well
according to the flat earthers and all
these other people they think it's that
which you can see or touch but it's an
irrational definition because we cannot
see all objects we cannot touch all
objects certainly we cannot touch that
planet that's on the other side of the
universe or the table that the klingon
has on the other side of the universe
does is that is a table is the word
table does that refer to an object
yes or no does uh a table exist if the
klingon is on the other side of the
universe putting his coffee cup
on the table but he can see and touch it
yeah but i can't but i can't
but i can't so for me it doesn't exist
foreign
but see the problem the problem is then
we say well for him it exists but for me
it doesn't oh man now we're getting into
weird territory yeah what do you mean
it doesn't exist for me i mean either
the table exists or doesn't matter no i
mean some people would postulate
philosophers among others that everyone
that what existence is subjective so
yeah your existence is different than my
existence etc not true in physics in
physics we define the word exist so that
all objects in the universe that are
there exist and it has nothing to do
with see or with touch you can't run an
experiment to prove what exists
okay that's where the error is of
flatlanders i guess the the the answer
to that would be before there was
consciousness on earth the moon and sun
still were so
they're they are independent of our
seeing now except no but
you probably would have to argue with
them all day long and they might say
well no they began to exist as soon as
we opened our eyes
i mean they're they're obviously older
than we are well you can imagine the uh
blind man who's deaf you know a poor guy
for him the moon doesn't exist right
so so for him he can't say well the moon
exists because of this definition he has
to see and touch it he can't see or
touch it for for him
for you to exist but for him it doesn't
but if you
the guy can feel the waves of the ocean
which are caused by
well caused by god
maybe spirits i don't know who knows
what causes that
newton was wrong nothing to do with the
moon
okay so here we have the definition
exists physical presence that's what the
word exists means what does physical
mean object what does presence mean
location what is an object that which
has shape what is location the set of
distances from one object to all the
rest in the system under analysis so if
god wants to exist first he's got to be
an object god cannot be a concept like
love or spirit he has to have shape yeah
he has to have shape according to that
definition and then that's not enough if
he wants to exist he needs something
else which is location set of distances
to the tree the rock the table etcetera
everything in the universe you mean we
do not we do not use any of the senses
the only sense is common sense the least
common of all senses true true but i
guess by by this definition
if god does exist he's findable
we'll find him in fact we don't have to
find him uh he exists by definition if
he has if there's distance between my
chest and his chest he exists by
definition even if we don't know where
he is yeah i don't have to i don't have
to touch him i don't have to see him he
can be in the 25th dimension for all we
care as long as there's a straight line
of direction from me to him he exists
we're done by definition by definition
the word exists
and that applies to any object in the
universe so this notion that an object
is that which you can see touch exists
is that which you can see touch that's
where the irrationality of the flat
earthers mathematical physics electric
universe john chappelle society all
these people have it wrong they have it
irrational they think an object is that
which you can see or touch no it ain't
that's an irrational definition okay so
um
here we have a situation
uh
this is a spoon falling okay this is
what i'm gonna show you okay
here's the spoon we're gonna let it go
okay it's gonna fall to the ground okay
that's
very very dangerous experiment don't do
it unless you're in the presence of a
relativist okay
okay so i can do it so here's the spoon
this is what you would see
just do it at home just let go of a
spoon always in the presence of a
relativist right and you can see that
you cannot see
the uh what's
below or above the spoon all you see is
the spoon falling to the floor okay
that's all you see
what are we saying where are we saying
that this is what's happening every atom
of the spoon is connected to every atom
on earth of course i didn't draw all the
connections there you have to imagine
that it's gazillions of atoms that
already looks like a lot of work yeah so
all we have is just the spoon falling
because every atom that makes up the
spoon is connected to every single atom
on earth in fact to every atom that
comprises your body that looks kind of
cool actually okay so this is this is
our explanation of why a spoon falls to
the floor no density no weight no
abstract concepts there's a physical
object connecting every atom on earth to
every atom of the spoon that's why the
moon the spoon falls as it falls the
reason it accelerates is the
uh ropes in this case which are the
mediators
widen they they open up and so they all
so they're not all on the same axis now
they form new axes as the spoon gets
closer and closer to the center of the
earth that's the explanation that we
give for gravity
we don't care if you believe it we want
you to understand what i just said okay
we want you to understand the mechanism
of what we're proposing for gravity so
don't tell me you don't believe it that
what about these robes and we don't care
about all that do you understand what i
just explained why what causes the spoon
to fall to the floor
the
every atom is connected to the earth and
as it falls
the
ropes are
are not pulling but there are more ropes
that are not on the same axis okay
because they're they're widening out
they're fanning out that's what's
happening so you have
not more ropes but you have more ropes
on different angles yeah that's what
we're saying because every atom is
connected just visualize what i'm saying
and you're going to understand the
mechanism all we want you to do is
understand the mechanism we don't care
if you believe it or not it's not
important well it still begs a lot of
questions but yeah yeah yeah how to
unpack right for example but we have to
start by understanding yeah but there's
a lot they have to unpack to understand
it for example it's also proximity based
because there's a lot of atoms on the
other side of that spoon that we're not
taking into account account so
there's a lot of questions and it's a
question of distance there you know so
we're not going to get into the details
all i'm saying is try to understand
before we kill you that's the simple
explanation that's the simple very
simple explanation as the phone gets
spooned gets closer and closer to the
center of the global earth right
uh the ropes fan out that's it that's
all you have to understand if you
understood it we're done
you believe it or not that's something
that talk to your priest on sunday okay
sunday school okay
okay so what are we saying here we have
it again one more time just so that we
rub it in here's the spoon
okay it's standing in midair
what is happening well what is happening
is the spoon is gonna fall to the floor
okay and where is that floor well is the
floor is sitting on the earth now i drew
a global earth you can draw a flat earth
we don't care but the floor hopefully is
on the earth right i hope the flat
earthers at least agree with that right
we're a step by step right okay we go
very the baby are you from space like
that yeah yeah okay so we're gonna drive
now this is inside your room but all i'm
saying here is the floor is on the earth
now the earth could be flat or curved it
doesn't matter hopefully the floor is on
the earth okay
so what are we saying in under the rope
model we're saying that every atom of
the spoon is connected to every atom of
the floor and of the earth
okay that's that's the mechanism we're
proposing we want you just to understand
okay just understand what we're saying
okay we don't want you to believe it we
don't want you to uh
you know convinced being convinced we
just want you to understand what we're
saying that every atom of the spoon is
connected to every atom on earth and
therefore it has to be a global earth
okay it can't be a flat earth
okay so now we have uh where did we get
this here we have mr mueller he's a uh
professor
at the authority hey yeah here we have
authority but all he's going to do is
regurgitate the law of gravity from a
mathematical point of view and this is
what he's his conclusion
into physics how he draws that into
physics he's saying that so for example
if you have the earth there's a big mass
here and you can see he drew the big m
there a little circle right that's the
earth and you have you with your little
mass here and that's you standing on the
earth right
every atom on the earth is pulling on
every atom of you
you're also pulling on it okay so that
means that if you're pulling on every
atom on earth that means every atom of
your body is connected physically
connected somehow to every atom in the
earth
okay do we have that
the amazing thing about gravity is that
it goes right through things
it goes through things the only way you
can explain that is if every atom in
your body is connected to every atom on
earth so it doesn't matter if there's an
atom in front of the other atom it goes
right through both of them because
you're connected to both atoms that's
what we're saying here okay so that's
where we got it and this explains
newton's
uh universal law
okay and i'll get to that in a minute
because fellow asked that question okay
so um so here we have it uh that's in a
nutshell what we have for the flat
earthers the flat earthers should not
request demonstrations
proofs
experiments we're not going to prove the
invisible intangible with any of those
we just did and you cannot explain using
you cannot explain using the word
density weight
uh i don't know a frame of reference you
know you can't use those concepts you
have to tell you have to draw the
physical object invisible
object that is mediating that
transaction
are you saying that instead of using
density they should use every
ball atom in the air
no all i'm saying is
if if you're going to say that the car
moves forward and because of that the
air moves to the back of the car and
that's what pushes the balloon forward
fine no problem you have to explain why
the air went back
and why
there's higher density in the back of
the room that's what we need to find out
yeah let's say that's how density works
you cannot just say that's just density
you have to say why what caused
each atom each molecule of air to go to
the back of the car that's what you
gotta explain and that's uh so something
pushed or pulled down the air
with respect to the car the car went
forward the air went backwards why why
did the air go backward i i pushed i
pulled
i accelerated the car i did not touch
the air
okay so why did the air go back and i'm
saying that every
molecule of air is connected to every
atom on earth so it's like a tree
okay the tree is on the ground when the
car moves forward the trees don't move
with the car because they're stuck to
the ground so with respect to the car
the trees are
in the back right that's what i'm saying
and that's what's happening exactly with
the molecules the molecules accumulate
in the back because they're tied to the
earth okay but that's what makes this
sound like a loaded question because
you're you're basically
answering a question that nobody had but
it was a question
because everyone took that for granted
the the inertia thing everybody kind of
takes it for granted oh you have to play
if the plane goes forward everything
goes back but you're saying no there's a
reason for that right it isn't just yeah
have a cause i mean on some levels some
people as like at that level of
abstraction people go oh that's just how
it is but you're saying no no there's
one more there's a reason for that right
you're answering a question that no one
had right that's why it sounds like a
loaded question the way you ask the
question
people just go with descriptions that's
the problem no because at some point you
have to say that's just how it is no no
no this is the issue the issue is that
people just measure and they say well
there's more density here than over
there
but you haven't answered the question
all you have is a description saying
well yeah there's more air over here
than over there but you haven't
explained why is there more error yeah
but inertia
is is the that's just how it is for
that's where that's where their logic
question stops yeah yeah yeah but you do
that too at some point you have to say
this is how it is why is the rope you
know the shape that it is oh that's just
how it is at some point but that's
different than saying that's different
than saying that
because you're explaining the cause and
that's where it all ends that is the
last question that's what i mean the
last question hold it let me finish that
the last question is
why does the air move to the back
because it's stuck to the earth now you
can say why is it stuck to the earth
that's an irrational question and it
takes a long time to explain that to
people you're asking a question of
philosophy which is reason purpose in
the context of physics which is causes
and mechanisms well that's where the
problem is it's not that
it's not that the questions are endless
it's that now you entered into
irrational questions you're asking
introducing philosophy which is reasons
and
purposes you know god did this because
he had a headache that sort of thing
yeah why did he do that
that's not the that's that's not part of
physics physics is explain the mechanism
the mechanism stops the last question
stops at the atom is connected to the
earth you understand that now you
understand the mechanism oh yeah but
they just stopped one before that which
is what which is that's oh yeah they
stopped it right they stopped the
density inertia that was enough for them
but you're like no there's a reason for
that as well and that's the one they
never figured out definitely
never figured a question that no one had
yeah because because no one questioned
the inertia thing no and the reason
there's a reason for that as well and
that is because people can't see or
touch what's there so they said well we
can't answer that question we'll never
answer that
which is wrong because you have to
visualize it you're not going to run it
through it you're not going to figure it
out through an experiment you're just
going to have to visualize how mother
nature is doing that uh phenomena
okay we got that yeah okay let's move on
to the subject of today which is true
jeez we're trying to get the truth yeah
we uh the truth that's true what's the
truth okay so let's recap a little bit
of what we did and that is this we have
philosophy okay
love of wisdom uh the as defined by the
uh greeks wait we've departed from
physics we're doing philosophy no not
well yes uh we're trying to contrast
philosophy against physics that's all
we're doing here okay so it's not that
we're going to be doing or really
getting into philosophy we're just
trying to
say first that philosophy is part of
science and then we want to distinguish
it from physics that's that's the
purpose here that's the goal okay so
here we start where the uh greeks
started essentially you know and that is
that um they um define philosophy as
love of wisdom that's i think the exact
translation of philos of the word
philosophy okay that's at least the
translation we have today and that's a
meaningless definition
if that's what the word stands for
that's fine we'll call it philosophy we
can also call it love of wisdom now we
have to define what we mean by love of
wisdom how is it defined well a lot of
people say well it's just a way of
thinking
so everybody's got a way of thinking you
have a way of thinking i have a way of
thinking so everybody's a philosopher we
got eight billion philosophers and so
how is aristotle different than us why
do we say oh he was a philosopher and so
what am i i'm a philosopher do i have a
way of thinking too yeah well we're also
what's wrong with that yeah so so it's
uh that's what's um irrational the fact
that we we're using a notion or a
definition that does not tell us what
philosophy is you know if philosophy is
just a way of thinking we haven't said
anything and what we do here we say
science is rational explanations within
that philosophy is rational explanations
of reasons and purposes
now we can fit philosophy within science
and not above science it's not that
philosophy is the mother of all sciences
is that philosophy is a branch of
science we got that so yeah the uh
greeks that's why i crossed them out you
know the uh
uh pathogen down there uh you know
uh still sounds like stamp collecting to
me bumps oh it does oh okay why tell me
all that categorization like i still
don't understand the if it's philosophy
or science as long as we understand the
question
and we answer the question who cares
what brief his biology
there's a couple things here the first
one is we can't say that aristotle was a
philosopher because we're all
philosophers that's that's what's wrong
no no no it's not opinion it's by
definition if if if philosophy is a way
of thinking we're all philosophy yeah
that's the first that's true okay the
second one is i go to the university i'm
going to study philosophy oh what are
you studying i'm studying opinions way
of thinking yeah
yeah what is that what what the hell you
got it that's exactly it that's exactly
nonsense you have not misrepresented it
at all
what did you study opinions yeah i
studied regulations
i studied uh uh eight billion ways of
thinking that's exactly what they do
recommendation yeah that's my philosophy
this is a problem okay so uh here's a
comment someone made okay uh ah
what happened here
okay
and since why don't i have this oh hold
it here i think it's this jesus
is that what it was
the video thing isn't working i don't
know what happened here
okay i gotta skip that one i don't know
what happened to that uh thingy what
were you gonna say
uh well i had some definitions of what
philosophy is according to the
dictionary so i guess i'm gonna have to
skip that okay here we have plato okay
he we talked about him the other day the
fact that
uh he said knowledge is justified true
belief essentially that's what came out
of his book belief belief
the theaters uh that's his book and
there he essentially has socrates
talking to theaters and
and plato essentially
you know after the death after the
suicide the forced suicide of socrates
he tells us how it would have happened
in the presence of socrates this is how
the
discussion would have taken place and
these were the arguments that socrates
raised so he raises a series of
arguments to show that uh eventually
right that he concludes that now this is
just justified true belief and that's
the definition that has survived for the
last 2 500 years that's what we have
today nothing has changed even with a
gettier problem and other
analysis that we see out there we all
end up with the same thing it's just
justified true belief what is justified
a belief what is true
uh we're going to argue today that
that's a belief too okay and what is
belief was belief so we have belief
belief belief that's what knowledge is
just uh three beliefs believe believe
believe me i believe i believe well i
believe three times so he believes
harder that's what you're saying so what
is knowledge it's belief it's opinion
and what is opinion what is belief
religion it's not science sciences now
and not knowledge science is rational
explanations okay so let's all put that
in in the right context that's what we
argued this week uh this month really
and uh we don't ask you to agree with it
we don't ask you to believe in it we ask
you to if you don't like it fight us
you know um challenge us
come up with a better mousetrap show us
that now there's just something other
than believe define it don't don't begin
talking about bill you're wrong
knowledge is not believed because you're
you're wrong and whatever we don't care
about that just give us your definition
of the word knowledge before you begin
to say anything because people like to
go in there and say well you're wrong
and i don't agree with you we don't care
about that
define the word knowledge and we'll know
what you mean right now this then we'll
know
okay yeah then we'll know we'll believe
we'll know what knowledge is right we'll
believe it don't believe what knowledge
is oh [ __ ] okay so a fellow says in
there he says
knowledge does not equate to belief whoa
and should not be considered synonymous
with beliefs okay
and if that's how it's been defined
since the days of aristotle then that's
most unfortunate okay what is knowledge
according to this gentleman he says
knowledge is awareness
awareness okay of objective reality
objective realities objective these are
objective realities which can be
empirically verified by all others okay
let's find out he says i know my finger
was cut off
well that sounds like knowledge he knows
right that his finger they just cut his
finger i mean if he doesn't know that he
don't know squash
so let's find out if this is knowledge
okay
he says this is knowledge according to
him it's awareness he's aware of an
objective reality the objective reality
is that his fingers no longer he's got
nine figures okay
he cut his finger off okay so it's a he
knows this okay so everybody would say
well yeah it looks like that's knowledge
right sounds like democracy
i see his fingers cut off too well let's
find out if this is knowledge okay it is
no longer a belief but rather a
statement of objective reality i'm
merely recognizing okay
knowledge is based on direct experience
with objective certainty or at least
should be should be
okay okay so this is the same thing as
the three stooges there
larry says i don't believe
i know
and mo says yeah i don't believe you
know either
yeah what's the problem with what this
uh fellow says well belief is what you
know only yourself
and knowledge is what you prove to
others
okay so here you he says he cut his
finger
and he says that's knowledge because he
has direct experience he knows
he cut his finger
well the first problem there he hasn't
defined the word knowledge he says
awareness okay so so let's find out
let's go with this definition he says
he's aware he doesn't have a finger they
lost a finger
okay i'm on the other side of the planet
and i'm in contact with him by phone i
don't have video even if i had video he
could be faking it he doesn't want to
come to work that day he says i took my
finger
and i said well i don't believe you
how's he gonna prove it he's on the
other side of the planet well uh i have
my company
in china i buy a company in china right
and i live in europe right and so he cut
his finger in china and he calls me he
says boss i can't come to work because i
cut my finger off i only have nine
fingers
and i said well you're a bum you never
come to work now you're giving me this
lame excuse that you lost a finger and
that they're gonna sew it on at the
hospital and that's why you can't come
to work okay so i got a problem with
that because i'm saying you're lying
your belief is right and i'm saying hold
it you know i cut my finger i don't i've
got nine fingers boss
and i'm saying prove it
show me your knowledge we have that
exact same thing going on in the chat
here with proof yeah and so it's all
proven and so so the issue is
now that's just something you have to
prove to someone else if you only have
your knowledge to yourself it's called a
belief awesome we do have a difference
between the two yeah because if you only
proved it to yourself and are aware
of it for yourself what do you have you
have a belief the only way you're going
to prove knowledge is someone else
believe you can prove only to yourself
now that you have to prove this to the
rest of the world but that is is a good
uh connection there no did you say
let's go with this could you say that
belief is the share sorry knowledge
is shared belief have they gone there
if one of them was shareable i think we
were going to get in there
we know this where's my we know don't
roll around just smack it
okay you're the only guy on the island
okay and you're aware you know blah blah
blah you believe because you're the only
guy there let's let's take it with
something that is more
uh deeply involved with knowledge and
belief god good old god
you know god exists
okay because you know it for whatever
reason the beautiful flower the bee
buzzing around only god could have made
it so you know god exit
okay so now prove it to someone else i
mean if you have yourself we call that
knowledge or we call it belief is this
the same thing as cutting your finger
where you have an awareness and you say
well i know i cut my finger well you
know
but i don't
you know that
the killer stabbed
the victim in the chest
and kill them
because you were there
the jury wasn't there the jury is just
relying on your word prove it prove your
knowledge how are you going to prove
your knowledge your awareness to someone
else
because if if only you have it we call
that belief yeah but if uh you what
share it yeah we should we're the jury
but see the jury doesn't believe you no
but then you don't share this
well if i don't share your no i don't
know
i mean like we have if we have the same
belief
would that be knowledge
well uh you and the jury believe it you
share that belief but the guy outside of
the planet doesn't believe it because he
doesn't know
right
that was too many examples so so what do
you guys think one example well so we do
we have to uh convince every
uh intelligent being in the universe
for it to be knowledge then we say now
it's knowledge because we have a hundred
percent of people and the religious
people are sure are trying
they're trying to convince everyone and
the reason you know i bring up uh this
as a background first because we did
philosophy belief and knowledge but
there's another reason here and that's
that all this has to
do with fact proof and
truth
that's how we're getting to truth to the
truth we're arriving at the truth so i
hope i hope fact proof and truth are
synonyms
okay so here we have another file says
again they copy paste a lot of these uh
definitions they don't analyze them so
he says no be aware again awareness okay
of through
uh
uh through observation inquiry or
information okay
okay so you're you're
you're being aware of something through
observation inquiry or information what
is belief and acceptance that a
statement is true or that something
exists
okay
so again uh this is the rundown you
prove your knowledge to your neighbor
who did not observe and is unaware okay
that's what you have to do prove it to
him
okay don't prove it to yourself because
then you're like the guy on the right
you know he thinks he's great because
he's proved it to himself so
so his belief has turned into knowledge
okay for him he knows it why because he
believes it but it's when you try to
convince someone else when you try to
prove it to someone else that you run
into trouble with knowledge okay and
then the question is are you aware or
unaware of god you know if you're aware
uh you call that guy a theist or a
theist and if you're unaware you call
him an atheist
that's all we have right that's that's
where as far as awareness goes
did you observe god or space-time did
you observe them with your eyes like how
did you observe it you know so if if
knowledge requires observation
did we observe the black hole did we
observe space-time did we observe dark
energy okay or energy of any kind like
they would say we've observed
derivatives yeah we we deserve the
outcome the what we can't see
not the invisible object that caused it
that's what i mean by derivatives we
don't see god we see his effects on yeah
right and so we infer god first based on
we infer energy and so on
and so aware is what acceptance meaning
belief so when you say that knowledge is
awareness all you're saying is belief
again
so he says be aware
through observation well all you're
saying is that you believe it that's all
it is
uh in science we have a little different
notion of all this acceptance of a
statement that a statement is true
that's known as an assumption we make an
assumption when we say okay i'm going to
accept that it's true i'm going to say
accept it as a fact for the purposes of
understanding the theory founded upon it
that's how we look at that
you don't have to believe it okay it's
just an assumption so that you
understand the theory and you can see
the assumption to understand the theory
found it upon it
chair exists whether you believe or not
or no or whatever okay the chair exists
by definition not because you believe
that it exists or that you've seen or
touch it okay we have to define the word
exist
and then based on that the chair exists
or not based on the definition not
because of your subjective notion
belief or knowledge or whatever you want
to call it proof fact
okay so here's the definition of truth
okay okay
and uh so it's related to proof fact and
knowledge uh these words are all related
in one way or another and here you see
the definitions of dictionary.com and of
the wikipedia and i've colored them in
so that you can follow
how this is all circular because all
they're using is synonyms truths
conformity with what fact or reality was
fact something that actually exists
what
or reality again and truth so we're back
to truth juggling the same word yeah
then reality was that the state of
quality being what real what is real uh
the word that we're trying to define and
real thing or fact what is fact well we
just covered that it exists or reality
the truth
so all we did was go around and circle
we haven't learned anything uh hopefully
the wikipedia does a little better so we
look it up and says true the property of
being in accord with what fact or
reality what is fact something that is
true
i love that what is reality well the sum
of aggregate or aggregate of all that is
real or existent within a system as
opposed to that which is only imaginary
what is existence the ability of an
entity to interact with reality okay so
yeah i hope you understood all of that
okay
yeah it's all circular we don't have a
single definition of any of these words
we have no idea what they mean because
they never defined them and uh
and
so whether you go to dictionary or
encyclopedia you won't find an answer to
your question if you want to know what a
fact is what reality is what existence
is what i'll say but truth is they're
all synonymous everyone just takes you
to the other now let's prove they're all
circular okay it's like we all know the
notion but no one has but no one knows
how to put in no we're gonna put the
finger on here you know and they say
well you can't define any words because
then you would have to define all those
words that you find as words and it's
just uh you know uh recursive
okay so here's the stanford encyclopedia
hopefully they did better i mean these
guys are professional philosophers of
all
and here truth is one of the central
subjects in philosophy great that means
that we're going to have a good
definition here the problem of truth is
uh oh the problem of truth what truths
are and what if anything makes them true
okay but this simple statement masks a
great deal of controversy i'm sure it
does so so far they say look uh truth is
gonna be a problem and there's a big
debate
raging for thousands of years right and
it's still controversial
okay so they go in here and they say a
belief is true what are they gonna talk
about
true beliefs
well your belief has to be different
than my belief or likely is or maybe
and so how does truth is if truth has to
do with belief we're already screwed
we're both we're both true they're both
true yeah yeah we're both true god
exists and god doesn't address both true
you know so we have a problem because if
it depends on belief it already depends
yeah it's subjective which is actually
the closest thing to truth actually
depends on who you ask
and only if it corresponds to a fact
what is the fact well we looked it up i
remember what a fact was it was uh you
know uh truth
truth is sex is factory to believe
these are statements that you'll see in
the uh in the article on truth okay this
is where i pulled out i like the next
one truth is the end of inquiry i think
that's my favorite one out of all of
them that is the one that hits it on the
nose well the end of it
yeah
when you stop asking questions when you
say that's just how it is that's the
truth that's the truth i don't wanna do
i give up for me i go one step further
yeah but for me i give up on this line
and that would be true i think that
really is the closest thing okay and i
said p is true just if it is identical
with a fact
so what is fact well fact is truth and
so on down the line so uh
then they talk about theories of facts a
theory of facts what the hell is that
facts and knowledge justified in
believing that that's
what truth is
but truth is the end of inquiry i think
that was those that's when you like
that's the one i like okay all of them
so we have a definition finally the end
of inquiry
that so what is the the issue the issue
is here you have the stanford
encyclopedia philosophy which the only
word it can't define is the word
philosophy you will not find the word
philosophy defined in the sanford
encyclopedia of philosophy
they're telling you not only they don't
understand what the word knowledge is
what the word belief is but they don't
know what the truth is what proof is
we're in the same boat as everybody else
there so you won't find an answer in the
stanford encyclopedia philosophy you can
skip that there's a long article if you
want to kill yourself you know you got
nothing better to do than read it
actually it's saying the word no or
knowledge is the end of inquiry that's
what truth truth is what god knows
right and truth is what god knows but no
is the end of inquiry that is when you
stop that taking the punchline away from
me oh shut up
okay but one more uh topic related to
that and that's
you have truth and what's the opposite
both fake false right fake news you know
and so here you have false not according
to truth or fact incorrect not true and
true so who determines that a jury
uh a judge who determines what is false
what is truth again uh all we're talking
about is opinion and you know i like to
tell ons all the time the following i
said truth
is what mother nature knows what uh uh
god knows what the father universe knows
what the devil knows they know exactly
what happened
they know exactly they have it in a file
cabinet this is exactly what happened
the problem is us humans we're mortals
you know we have no access to that file
cabinet because it's in the past
we don't know that napoleon went to
waterloo in 1815 we don't know this
always that's in their final cabinet
they know for sure but we don't we can
only rely on what someone told us
through the books through passing it on
from generation to generation and we
accept it and we say well yeah i think
that no one lied really here i think
napoleon went to waterloo but i cannot
prove it to you i cannot bring napoleon
1815 today and show them to you and say
this is napoleon in 1815. i can't do
that i can't bring neil armstrong
stepping on the moon in 1969
today and say look this is
how it happened i can't do that okay
unless we're talking about the block
universe where everything is determined
because then you just retrace your steps
where all the atoms were in
whatever date you need meaning god uh
mother nature father universe the devil
no
assuming you had that machine what was
the the time machine no not the time
machine dude go through the future item
calculating machine the one that can
tell you exactly oh yeah where every
atom in the universe is if you retrace
each atom steps then you could tell
where napoleon was at what date yeah if
you could do that you know but again uh
you would have to go to the past to that
point to 1815 and say okay yeah now
i verify that napoleon here yeah you
really raised the steps
yeah but that means you got to go back
in time because you're taking the
universe every atom back to where it was
you know 200 years ago can you just
calculate it well yeah
this is a fictional machine yeah
yeah i mean yeah if you had the the
location of every atom in the universe
and retrace it back but again i would
have to convince you of that even with a
computer i would have to say look if i
take all the atoms back i got all the
items in my computer right i got them
all in the universe and i take all that
back see this is where this uh adam was
this is where this galaxy was says who
if we if we have all that information
you know again only god has that
information in his file cabinet i don't
have that you know i can only guess so
truth is what god knows what mother
nature knows or you know uh uh truth
proof all this stuff in fact you know
this is what they know what these
deities know all we can do is make a
statement of the facts and say this is
what we think happened this is my
assumption and work from there i can say
let us assume we could be wrong this is
the best we have right let us assume
napoleon was in waterloo and you say
what do you mean assume of course he was
there well no you can't prove it to me
so we have to make an assumption and
it's a
an assumption you can almost put the
hand in the fire for because everybody
just passed it on to us aren't we kind
of trying to find which assumptions are
true
when we
because when we do physics when we every
time you're doing physics what you do is
you throw out a set of assumptions and
then you logically follow those
assumptions to his logical conclusion if
it doesn't make sense then the
assumptions were wrong right
or something was wrong with the
assumptions
and we keep doing this test to see which
assumptions are the best fit
that is what we do yeah yeah but there's
let me tell you what the problem is the
problem is with the moonies and flat
earthers who say
uh neil armstrong did not step on the
moon in 1969. yeah so you know this is
more or less like napoleon you know i
can't go back to napoleon to verify that
he really was in waterloo in 1815.
likewise i can't go back to 1969 and say
uh
napoleon landed on the moon
i can't see a neil armstrong landing on
the moon i can't you know i have to make
the assumption let us assume
and and then work from there onwards now
why do i make an assumption well first
of all because you know
i was there in 1969 i was here you
weren't there maybe you were born after
that so i was there you know i looked at
it i said yeah i think this happened and
i didn't i i wasn't on the moon you know
filming
you know armstrong stepping on the moon
i just looked at that it all sounded
real to me i think it was real and
that's what i believe that's the
assumption i work off of
the new generation they say well prove
it to me bill well i can't prove it to
you and i can't prove it to you for the
same reason i said so many times now
a movie of that made in hollywood is no
different than the real thing
and if you cannot tell the difference
between the real thing and a movie made
in hollywood you can't use that as an
argument against
the the the actual phenomenon that neil
armstrong landed on the moon you can't
say well that could have been done in
hollywood yeah it could have been done
no doubt about it and if you can't tell
the difference you can't use that as an
argument you can't say well that's be
that's the reason i don't believe
that uh neil armstrong landed on the
moon you can't use that because if you
can't tell the difference i can use that
same argument against you and say prove
to me that he didn't
and you say well that could have been
done in hollywood yeah i grant that and
what what have you said nothing so this
is the issue the issue i cannot prove to
you that no that napoleon was in
waterloo 1915. i just have to take it at
face value from what i read in the books
and say well it's a good chance that
that's what happened okay but yeah again
we can't prove these things truth
what mother nature knows okay see they
know the truth they know exactly what
happened they know whether the guy
stabbed the victim in the chest because
mother nature
logged that phenomena in her
book and put into file cabinet we have
no access to the file cabinet we can
only make an assumption
okay
okay let's go quickly with our science
critic uh here it is give me a second
here i'm going to put him on he's going
to argue that
mathematics is indispensable it's uh
it's requirement of physics okay
and i'm going to argue exactly the
opposite mathematics has nothing to do
with physics or with science so here it
goes okay give me a second i'll put them
on
you
okay there we go
in this rebuttal we will address the
issue of whether we need math in physics
was a very stupid thing to say bill
maths is pretty much essential for
physics if you don't have maths you
don't have physics there is a reason why
newton invented calculus in fact if you
have two competing hypotheses
how do you tell them part
well that will be done using maths
okay
so far says that uh the way they prove
hypothesis in uh mathematical physics or
in his version of science is by using
math
okay
uh first we have a difference in the
word hypothesis it has nothing to do
with theory
hypothesis is not a theory
uh in mathematical physics a hypothesis
is an unproven or a tentative theory
that's not what it is in real science
and science hypothesis are the objects
the definitions and the statement of the
facts in other words the first frames of
the movie then from there you build your
theory okay so we have a difference
there uh but let's get to the word math
is math
part of uh physics is math part of
science well in order to do that you
have to define what science is and what
physics is and that's where the problem
is these people have never defined the
word physics in a rational manner they
haven't defined the word science in a
rational manner they think that science
is just a series of descriptions and
we're saying science is explanations not
descriptions we have a difference there
and this is the rundown here real quick
science rational explanations physics
rational explanations of what
causes and mechanisms we have to have
an explanation of mechanisms of causes
that's what we don't have today and
you might say well i don't agree with
your definition bill okay no problem the
issue is the following uh i'm going to
ask you a question i'm going to say
is uh explaining how this magnet
attracts that other magnet right
is that a question of physics according
to you
do you think this is part of the subject
matter of physics explaining
how it is that one magnet attracts
another for example
is this part of physics yes if you say
that this is a question that physics has
to answer that it is a question of
physics
your the definition we have today of
science in a physics does not address
these types of questions the
mathematical physicists
and the scientists who got scientists
they say these questions are questions
of philosophy
and philosophy is outside the bounds of
physics and of science philosophy is the
mother of all sciences and blah blah
blah
and so this is not a question that
physics answers that's where the problem
is so we have irrational explanations
for example that warp space is gravity
uh that a particle can be two places at
once and when you say well that's
irrational and they say well yeah
because that's philosophy and we don't
care and that's not part of science
but that's the questions the type of
questions people ask for example in
quora they say how does a magnet attract
another
and you have all these mathematical
physics that come in there and they say
well here's the equation
this is
the
force with which one magnet attracts
another well that's not the question i'm
asking i'm asking what is the physical
mechanism of how a magnet attracts
another and you won't find an answer to
those questions because they don't
consider it part of physics part of
science that's what the problem is and
so again if mathematics
i'm sorry physics is
rational explanations of causes and
mechanisms that covers all physics
and if that's the case we don't need in
for an explanation we don't need math at
all
no no numbers no math no equations no
functions we don't need any of that
because with that you cannot explain
and if physics and science is about
explaining you cannot explain with math
you can only describe with math okay
that's the issue
you don't like my definition
come up with a better mousetrap give me
a definition that you can sink your
teeth into don't copy it from the
dictionary don't trans don't transcribe
it don't copy paste come up with a
definition that you can defend
for physics and then we'll find out if
mathematics has anything at all to do
with physics you can't use authority you
can't use tradition you can't use
democracy you can't say that's the way
we always did it
you can't say everybody in the universe
believes
in my version you can't say any of that
and you can't say well that's what i was
taught in college or in high school
authority you can't use any of those
come up with a definition that you can
defend okay
so um how does math
explain gravity for example how gravity
works but you can't do it with math you
can only tell me how strong
gravity is maybe but you cannot tell me
what caused it with an equation that's
why math has nothing to do with physics
physics is explaining physics is not
doing an equation that describes what
happened okay
um so mathematical physics is an
oxymoron because math describes physics
explains never the twin shall meet okay
you're trying to unite two things that
are incompatible
uh math is description and physics is
explanation
okay so that's my answer to this
gentleman and uh so
that ends that
okay let's go to the questions that
people ask here we have one file he says
is shape not a concept
yeah when i picture a perfect triangle
am i con conceptualizing an object or
objectifying a concept
well we won't have any idea until you
define what an object and a concept is
see unless you can define those two
words we have no idea what you said or
what's going through your mind i think
it means by your definition well by my
definition it's very simple a shape
there it is
shape is set of adjectives that we use
to qualify an object in physics we only
use adjectives to qualify or or modify
objects so you say that's triangular
that's circular uh that's cubic
those are adjectives that qualify
the shape of an object so shape is like
a big category that includes all these
adjectives underneath it and of course
the category and the adjectives are all
concepts okay what is a concept well
it's a word that invokes two objects
it's a relation between two objects but
that's a separate issue
if you want to understand under
whether an object is whether a shape is
an object or a concept just define the
word object and concept and we'll know
what's going through your mind okay we
need to understand what's going through
your mind yeah you have to explain
what's going through your mind to us
and by that the way you do that is
defining words that's where we start and
then we just work off of objective
definitions apply them objectively
okay second question fell says energy
that which animates an object
that's the definition of energy
okay so here we have an example uh gas
animates my car
okay
but it turns out that gas uh
this one at least equates with energy
right
and this is according to his definition
gave energy that which animates an
object uh gas is what animates my object
uh my car in this case an object right
and so he's equating gas with energy but
it turns out that gas is an object but
get energy is a concept it's defined as
capacity capacity is not a physical
object there's no stand-alone object
called capacity okay so
uh is energy an object or a concept
according to him to his definition if if
we're gonna define it as that which
animates an object that which animates
an object yeah they're just looking for
like we what we say you know the hair on
the egg
there there's no uh
chicken egg wait
i know which animates an object isn't
your definition no no that's his
definition i'm saying that he can't use
that definition because here we have an
example if gas animates my car meaning
it gets it to move gas is not energy we
say well
yeah
you're equating gas with energy but gas
is an object energy is a concept because
energy is defined as capacity there's no
physical object it is that which
generates an object not capacity
yeah but i mean
by his definition gas would be energy
no but see he's got a problem because
again he's got to tell us whether energy
is an object or a console what is it an
object here
right so he's saying an object but so uh
then he's got to define what an object
is he's got to say well what is an
object that which you can see or touch
you can't see your touch energy so even
under the understanding
under his definition you can touch gas
oh how
touch gas
well he can touch gas but he hasn't
shown that gas is energy yes because
that gas is what animates an object no
gas not energy he's saying energy is
that which animates an object yeah in
this case gas would be the energy right
no
he hasn't made the connection yet
between gas and energy that's my point
but in this example in this example gas
animates my car but energy
is not gas that's what he's saying it is
no he's saying energy is animates my car
not gas energy makes my car i'm saying
gas energy uh gas and gas animates my
car
okay and so he can't say that he can't
replace the word gas with energy he
hasn't made that he hasn't made that
step yet
and but he he is insinuating that that's
the case that's the issue and so again
gas is an object because you can touch
see it but you can't touch energy uh
to say that it's that
we don't know if he's talking about a
concept or an object okay so we go back
to what is an object what is a concept
he's got to define those two words first
okay uh phil says
we contain electricity and batteries
he contains electricity okay that's i'm
wondering what planet he's from i think
he's martian i don't know maybe a
klingon electricity has mass he says can
be weighed
we constantly store electrical energy
we can see electricity
jesus christ i wish i were in the same
planet he's in
we touch it we touch he touches
electricity
unbelievable
i wish i could do that
and he says my crossbow has capacity
uh yeah i don't know he i don't know
what planet he comes from you know how
what kind of crossbow he's got but he
says his crossbow has capacity
it's called energy
okay and energy is capacity
movement has mass and weight
what is this good saying
i mean
bartender i want to have whatever yeah
that's too many he said movement has
mass and wade he's just juggled around
yeah unbelievable well you know there's
there's no purpose in answering uh fella
obviously he's off his rocker anyways uh
here we have answers to those here's
electricity uh is the movement of
electrical charges so you can't weigh or
you can't say electricity has mass
because electricity is movement
okay
and
dictionary.com time rate of flow of
electrical charge so uh electricity is
either movement or flow meaning movement
in both cases uh electric universe
defines it as uh fundamental quality of
matter what is it exactly which we
define as the flow
of electric charge
which travels through a circuit
continuously electricity moves through
blah blah blah blah blah okay so yeah
electricity is motion of something and
you can't say you wave motion or that
motion has mass okay so
it's nonsense uh what this poor file
says anyways here
we say what energy energy is not a what
energy is a concept because it's defined
officially as the capacity the ability
there's no physical object called
capacity no physical object called
ability energy is not an object energy
is a concept concept has no shape or
location therefore do not move you can't
say you're going to move energy you're
going to transfer energy concepts cannot
be transferred from a to b okay
so yeah neither electricity nor nor
energy can be moved transferred or
touched they're not physical objects you
can't treat them as objects in physics
in ordinary speech you can say whatever
you want you can say love move mountains
it doesn't matter
okay if enough aloe if a rope connects
every atom in the universe what happens
when an atom splits into two smaller
atoms under fission
where in the world did he get that that
atoms can be split well he got it from
quantum mechanics because
it's based on the particle hypothesis
and what quantum mechanics cannot do is
draw an atom so they don't know if an
atom has been split because they cannot
draw an atom
they cannot tell you
what what have they split have they
split it in half with the proton have
they removed the electron from the
proton what is it that they split and
before they split it please draw the
atom so we can see what you're going to
split i mean if you're going to say
you're going to split the loaf of bread
first show me the loaf of bread and the
knife then you can talk about splitting
well quantum mechanics cannot draw
cannot illustrate a hydrogen atom for
you
because what are they going to
illustrate a little bead rolling around
a proton what keeps the bead tied to the
proton why does it fly away if they
cannot
give you an explanation for that they
cannot even start to tell you that they
split the atom okay so splitting the
atom is again belief
and it's an irrational belief because
you don't have an atom to begin with
they can't give you they can't
illustrate an atom for you okay no one
in quantum mechanics can draw for you
a proton and an electron
they can draw that but they'll say well
but that's not really our atom
so why did you draw it well because i
needed that atom to explain the
electricity ionization and who knows
what else you know uh quantum jump
so they draw that out then they get rid
of and they say well but don't believe
in that m that's not our atom
so what was their explanation worth if
they get rid of that atom they say
that's not our atom
you know a bore atom the planetary model
so if phel says two neuros instantly
connect two smaller of the two atoms to
every other atom in the universe
new ropes
he thinks that uh he's going to create
ropes from vacuum
turn space into a rope
well yeah because he's talking about
splitting yeah i know that's why these
people don't understand the theory so
yeah well this is just the following of
the previous one but again it's it's
based on these assumptions that
particles come in from the void and that
uh
the atom is composed of two particles
which is asking the question yeah but
see the point is that he's assuming
fission
but uh that's already an irrational uh
statement because there is no vision of
the atom especially if you're going to
translate that notion into the rope
model there is no fish and no breaking
of the atom not in in physics in in
the uh
rope model of the atom so creating new
ropes and
the other one says are the ropes form
faster than the speed of light you know
formed from where from vacuum i mean
what is this he's asking a question
yeah but he says you know
questions here but he's not
understanding the basics of the role
model there's a season
there's no creation in in in the rope
model there's a single
thread in all the entire universe and
that turns into all the ropes and atoms
so there's no creation of new thread of
new ropes of new atoms and there's no
disappearance no no atom converts into
space no rope converts into empty space
into vacuum yeah okay and when you
understand that you can't talk about
forming about creating about something
coming out of nowhere that's magic
that's what they have in quantum
mechanics you know virtual particles pop
in to make the equation come out right
then it goes back to b nothing
everything else that he wrote after that
was just uh the following of the first
assumption if
the atom splits then these following
questions would follow right and and
again what i'm saying here is that first
you reject his assumption the assumption
is already wrong that the atom splits
that's based on the
quantum version of the atom which is
based on particles okay and again they
don't have an explanation for that
either so they introduce virtual
particles meaning particles that they
suddenly need for the equation to come
out right because there's more mass more
charge and they say well suddenly this
came out of nowhere and we call that a
virtual particle it's it's known as
black magic
and they say well we don't understand it
of course nobody understands black magic
okay black magic has no random
cheating by definition yeah it's a it's
an irrational explanation they say well
it's black magic that's the way it works
down there because we can't see it we
can't touch it
that's all they're saying
okay another
fellow says talks about the inverse
square law is related to the uh rope
model he says how does the inverse
square law of gravity suggest ropes
seems to me that the inverse square is
particularly unuseful when considering
rows
exactly the opposite exactly the
opposite we fall completely within the
inverse square law okay and here it is
okay
uh when um uh astronauts farther away
from the earth he weighs less and when
he's closer to the earth he's weighs
more and the reason for that is there
are more ropes
that are fanned out the closer he is to
the earth we know that as
acceleration of gravity
and here's another version of that so
that you can see it okay this is how
gravity works okay you have two objects
and you can see the square of the
distance there on the right especially
okay
uh when the objects are close together
the ropes fan out more when they're out
uh far apart from each other the two
objects are far apart from each other
what you see is that all the ropes come
together and act as a single coaxial so
yeah the square of the distance is is
quite um
quite
in accordance with the rope model okay
we have no quarrel with the uh with a
with the
square of the distance function
and uh another value some along the same
line he says the following says if
gravity is propagated through ropes and
then he says ropes are less pulled
towards
and so i want to correct them first
gravity does not propagate through ropes
and ropes are not pulling
okay so
he wrote an entire paragraph on this and
so i'm going to reject it on these two
statements he's got these two statements
wrong okay this is where where he fails
so i just put those two statements out
of his entire paragraph what's the issue
the issue is the ropes don't pull
there's tension that's why i put the
letter t there which i uh circled there
well that squared it right
t stands for tension newton's equation
said force equals we say tension equals
tension is not a force as is uh
mathematical physics has always believed
or
uh assumed
uh tension is uh something different
than force okay tension nobody wins the
tug of
war force someone wins the tug of war
okay someone pulls or pushes uh and when
we talk about force tension is neither
pushed nor pull
okay so you have to understand that why
is the tension because the letter c 300
000 kilometers per second the speed of
light
is a constant in the universe and so
that little letter c assures that we
have tension and not pull okay the
tension on the rope is always the same
so the rope does not pull an atom does
not really pull on another atom what we
have is when you have many atoms the
rows fan out as two objects come closer
together as seen on the bottom right
okay
so uh no you can't talk about gravity
propagating through the ropes what
propagates is light okay meaning that
the rope torques in situ that's what
propagation means and as far as pulling
no the ropes don't pull there's tension
on the rope and that's indicated by the
constant speed of light
okay and here we have another fellow he
says you have no idea how many of bill's
lectures i've seen okay so i've seen a
bunch of them if bill is proposing a new
type of contiguous substance that is
sub-microscopic then he needs a
different word than rope
you can't use the same word in physics
for two very different things
okay he took this out of context again
um we're saying we're saying that light
whatever light is it's mediated by a
rope like entity it has the architecture
of a rope i also use the word dna you
know the the term dna i'm saying the
rope is a dna like helical structure
we call it a rope just to use the word
rope we call it the electromagnetic
world there's no a word for it there is
a light like
besides when you say electromagnetic
rope right when you say electromagnetic
road it conveys that you know everybody
gets the idea of what you're talking
about you're saying there's an
architecture that we can't see or touch
we'll call it the electromagnetic road
dna like helical pair of twine threads
anyway you want to state it and that's
what represents light thread ropes yeah
an elongated thing whatever you want
again these people take things out of
context i don't know
okay final issue fellow says
god does not exist
because the location of god is in my
head oh i'm sorry he says god does exist
because the location of god is in my
head right
i see god in my head therefore god has
location you can borrow my brain and see
for yourself
i'll pass on that one okay i don't want
to borrow your brain
who do you have the scarecrow's brain
[Laughter]
what can i say if god is in your brain i
feel so sorry for you try to take him
out of there okay
get rid of god because you know
he's going to per turn
okay so what do we have we have any
questions uh from folks today let's see
we got a lot of statements people
answering the questions that you've okay
asked throughout the thing see if we can
get something useful here otherwise
we'll postpone the question for next
time but let's see if we we can find
something here
there was one that i saw okay
see if you find it again
was mostly statements
people saying hello
hi
people answering questions airplanes in
contact with your hair and so on
again it's it's hard to create a
dialogue when everything's offset by
time like this oh yeah i know but you
know we have to cover some ground okay
that's one of the issues and so it's
very hard to have in a real-time
question and answer on the one hand on
the other there's a lot of people who
just make comments and so it's very hard
to find
the right question in the in the
in the sequence the other one is that
you know uh i like to in general give a
more um comprehensive answer and for
that you know you want to look at the
question think about it maybe do some
research and then i give you a valid
some
question some answer that you can take
to the bank
if if i just answer off the cuff you
know i could make an error you know
maybe and say oh holy i didn't think
that or maybe i didn't understand the
question well or whatever well here's
one that you can think of
if all atoms is talking about the plane
and the inertia thing right yeah okay if
all atoms are attached to every other
atom why doesn't everything travel at
the same speed
why don't you just go with the plane why
do you fall back at all okay because you
have remember you have distance
okay distance is a very important factor
in newton's equation okay and uh that's
just a description yeah but what i'm
saying here is that you gotta factor
distance anyways uh even if you don't
put any math to it just think of it this
is from where to where well the distance
uh between atoms uh
whatever the test object is oh yeah me
on the plane plane accelerates forward
why don't i
stay there
well again again because remember you're
tied
to every atom on earth okay so let's get
rid of the airplane for a second you're
just uh floating in the air
you're um i don't know parachutist so to
speak you're just in the air okay just
standing there in the air and like a
tree stuck to the ground because you
every atom of your body is connected to
the earth let's assume that uh we just
take a snapshot of that in other words
you're falling but we're going to take a
snapshot we catch you in midair
now let's put the airplane in there okay
so now you're inside the airplane for
that split second okay
the airplane accelerates as you're
falling momentarily because you're being
tugged by gravity but the floor of the
plane keeps you up there right
so right now you're you're pressing
against the floor of the airplane so
it's like the previous scenario where
you were just
parachuting but suddenly we took a
picture of you in mid-air yeah so no
different you're here you were just
standing in the middle of air and now
you're standing on the surface of the
train the airplane whatever in this case
let's talk about the airplane so you're
just standing there okay but you're
being tugged
you're being tugged
by the um every atom on earth in other
words you've got a tension right
i say tug because we're used to talking
about tugging and pulling but you've got
tension you're just
being tugged against the floor of the
airplane now the airplane accelerates
you're you're just you're just a tree
uh stuck on the ground
so the airplane's moving with respect to
you who's a tree standing on the ground
that's why you fall backwards because
the plane moves forward you don't move
with the airplane because you're a tree
stuck to the floor
that's essentially what's happening okay
you're not really stuck to the floor
what you're stuck is to the earth
the airplane moves forward but you are
stuck to the earth like a tree on the
ground that's what's happening so the
the airplane is moving with respect to
you you haven't moved essentially it's
the airplane that went away okay it's
like you know you're on a horse the
horse leaves and you're just sitting
there you know kind of thing
that's the notion that we have to convey
and that's what's happening to the air
inside the car as well the air is just
sitting there being tugged by the earth
okay suddenly the car moves forward all
that air is obviously gonna just stay
there you know and the back of the car
is gonna move all the air that was there
closer together now you have higher
density
now you have higher density it's like
you got a forest
okay you got a forest all the trees are
stuck to the ground
suddenly uh i don't know
a wall comes and sweeps across that
you know sweeps across that forest well
it's going to push all the
trees together because all the trees are
creating resistance because they're all
stuck to the floor
and this is more or less what's
happening to the atoms as well of air or
the molecules of air they're there the
the car moves forward crushes them all
against each other and you have higher
density okay and that higher density
pushes the balloon forward
okay that's what we're saying okay but
only because every atom is stuck to the
earth if every atom is just floating
independent if they're just discrete
atoms as the strength as as the
establishment holds that everything is
discrete atoms
why would the density accumulate
why would why don't they travel together
with a car
well what what forces one atom to be in
contact with another atom oh yeah they'd
have to explain gravity for that yeah
and and for that you have to tie that
atom to the earth there's no other way
you have to connect them here's one
that's often levied against you uh what
is the location of the rope
what is the location of the road well
the issue is that we usually when we
talk about location until today until
the rope model came along okay we always
talked about location in terms of atoms
of
uh what we call matter not the energy
which is the rope that interconnects two
pieces of matter two atoms so we've
never talked about
in the past until today until the rope
model we never talked about the location
of energy which is what we're replacing
with
the rope we're saying that the rope is
this so-called energy this so-called
wave that goes from one atom to another
so we've never talked about the location
of the rope but if you
with a new model yeah you can talk now
about the location of the rope because
if a rope connects two atoms all you
have to know is that you know you have
two atoms there and you have a row
connecting them and you have another
parallel set another atom with
connected with another robe to to
another atom now you can establish you
know a location of those two ropes
because now you're talking about real
things okay so yeah there's there's no
problem there except that again uh the
word location typically is applied to
atoms that's the that's the only issue
here okay
uh why do you hate mathematics if it
makes explaining geometric patterns easy
well i i tell you one thing i've taken
gazillions of courses of math i'm very
well versed in math okay
i'm saying math has nothing to do with
physics or with science so it's not that
i hate math in fact i love math i i love
calculus took many calculus courses so i
have nothing against math i'm just
saying math has nothing to do with
physics or science it doesn't matter
because it doesn't explain and i'm
saying that
physics and science is about explaining
math is only descriptions okay what is
an equation an equation is just a
description of motion that's all it is
what you do is you calculate one value
then you change the variable calculate
the second value
change the value calculate a third uh
value and you plot those and you say
okay that we have motion
we can we can say that this mass
the
point mass of the weight of the elephant
to what for example right and now it's
here now it's there now it's there now
we have motion you could say it's a long
recipe for counting yeah all you're
doing is calculating locations where the
value is at that's all you're doing with
with an equation an equation cannot tell
you what caused you know the pen to fall
to the floor
that's that's what we're seeing those
kinds of questions cannot be answered by
mathematics and therefore by
mathematical physics and that's why we
have no explanations for why the pen
falls to the
floor rather than to the ceiling now
there's still people who want you to
respond to people's definitions but i
guess you'd have to look through the
list of okay well if you have uh
questions of definitions first put your
definition
okay and i'll be glad to answer them
i'll look them up uh next time i'll see
what uh issues you have with those
definitions and let's fight put on your
gloves
put up your dukes and let's fight
we'll see you next time okay bye bye